one of the things we look forward to the
most at the acms besides the
performances
is the fashion here to break down all of
the
looks that we saw on the red carpet is
e.t senior style editor
marissa runyon and celebrity stylist
dear friend of mine and designer of
daniel diamond
daniel musto you guys let's start off
with the lady who was all over the acms
performing three different times i'm
talking about miranda
lambert marissa can you start breaking
down
her look and well actually looks because
they were plural and why she was just
everything
yes you know miranda is one of those
people who's so comfortable in her own
skin
and she always has a way of not letting
clothes wear her she just
is and she's comfortable and i really
love that she went a little over the top
with her first performance look
with elle king i loved this exaggerated
fringe i love that they had this like
coordinated twinning moment
it was over the top in just the right
way and it went so perfectly with the
song
we're performing which was so fun and
playful i thought this was
perfect well daniel is the master of
bedazzle and fringe daniel what was your
thoughts
on miranda's look i love
miranda and friends she's actually a fan
of daniel diamond she actually gifted
marin moore some jackets earlier this
year
so marin got to have her diamond fringe
moment with daniel diamond and now she's
doing this jacket which is actually from
a showroom i love in la called maison
prive
and to do something so dramatic give us
that car wash moment
because we all know country music is
camp it's theatrical and if anyone's
going to step in and do it
it's miranda and i think the most
beautiful thing about miranda also going
so deep in this
inside info miranda hates getting
dressed she hates that side of the
business
so knowing that she actually camped up
like this got in a pink car
and just was like el king let's go it's
huge for me
meanwhile i feel like someone who does
love to get dressed up and and get all
the glam
is carrie underwood y'all let's break
down this look marissa
who was she wearing do we know who she
was wearing or is she leaving us to
guess
i have been searching high and low for
the details on this dress because the
minute she
opened her mouth and i saw her in that
light with that
stained glass window behind her she
looked like a literal angel
so i need to know the details i don't we
don't know yet but i would imagine it's
something custom she just
she looked like an actual angel she was
just glowing
inside and out that performance put
tears in my eyes it was so so stunning
speaking of tears in my eyes had tears
in my eyes when gabby barrett performed
and i love that she's always so
age-appropriate with her looks and she
just looked
so casual but chic when she performed
daniel what were your thoughts on this
look i know you love a good hat moment
i love a hat moment and i love gabby
barrett she's actually dressed by the
same stylist
tiffany gifford who does shania miranda
and mickey guyton
and she just kills it on her especially
coming out of you know she just had a
baby not long ago
i can't imagine i ate a burger yesterday
and i'm not showing you anything
below this body because i just can't
i don't know how these girls get on
stage so her and these high-waisted
jeans with that beautiful top
it's feeling ethereal but it also has
that like hipster
instagram country moment with the hat
i'm here for it she looks amazing in
malibu and not trying too hard at all
either
i want to show some love to the gents at
the acm awards too
talking about leslie jordan y'all leslie
jordan made an acm awards debut
up cameo and it was everything marissa
what was he in
honestly he was my best dress of the
night the minute i saw him i was like
best dressed hands down you know he he
actually posted a hilarious
behind-the-scenes look
at him getting ready on his instagram
you gotta see it take a look
getting ready for the acm awards is
exhausting
i bet mickey guyton and keith urban
don't have to iron their own clothes
oh brother
oh my goodness i love him so much hey
daniel um i feel like you
and leslie would be the dynamic duo
taking over nashville
can you please add him to your roster of
clients please
i'm being told that leslie and i have to
meet he's giving me like betty white
meets todd chrisley all decked out in
his nudie style suit which you know is
one of the reasons i do what i do and i
love what i love is because of the
nudie's brand
um so no and look at him look they said
show the bottom of the shoe and he
staged joe into the step and repeat well
you both thank you
so much for joining us here on et live
to recap the acm awards fashion
y'all look great i'm seeing you on the
monitor i love you both so much
daniel musto co-founder of daniel
diamond and marissa runyon e.t senior
style producer thank you so much
we are just about wrapped here recapping
the acm awards for all thing hcms
make sure you head on over to online.com
and tune into entertainment tonight
tomorrow as e.t is backstage
right now in nashville with the winners
[Music]
bye